so you were a Catholic right is that is
that correct I was so Catholic I was an
altar server I did bread and water fasts
as a child for the souls in purgatory
like oh child abuse dude my mom was so
Catholic it's crazy like she would put
like Benedict medals over all the I
write about this in this over the doors
and like to keep the devil out so I grew
up being like scared of the devil but I
also thought I had this like benevolent
being looking out for me so maybe that's
why like I've been pretty needy in a lot
of my relationships until I got a lot of
therapy because like nobody can be God
but
um I I fell away from that for several
reasons I mean I was so Catholic I
thought I was going like I would go to a
confession and tell the priests
everything like that I was doing that
was bad even if it like when I got older
and the sins were like you know weirder
things to talk to a strange old man
about and I yeah I truly thought I was
going to hell and I fell away from it
for a few reasons partially because I
don't agree with a lot of the stuff but
like I don't feel like if you masturbate
and I write about this in the book and
you like crash your car on the way to
confession that you should go to hell
forever like I think that's a little
it's like not cool and I also just make
a lot of sense no it doesn't and I also
feel like and I do actually I have a lot
of my mom's family that is very Catholic
and they've had a heart as I talk openly
about this and they have a hard time
being like they think I'm going to hell
because I'm not Catholic anymore and
they will really go in on me I'm like
but you love me you're capable of loving
me even though I'm not so like wouldn't
God be capable of loving me
um so I it's religion is definitely a
taboo one especially
you know for me to talk about and it's
just you have to because I kind of like
suffer I thought it was so bad for a
long time well I mean that right there
is one reason to be suspicious if
something makes you feel so bad all the
time how can it be that good when we're
literally just finishing a topic about
laughter is healing it's like guilt and
shame are literally the lowest frequency
energies that you can emit I was dating
this guy and he was Christian I made
some funny comment about it was like
some it was like the Jim Carrey moment
when he was on the red carpet and
started talking about tetrahedrons and
oh we're just dancing so I was repeating
that and then he was like oh we're going
to get her to talk to the priest and
straighten her out or talk to the pastor
and straighten her out talking about me
and I looked and if looks could kill I
was a newsy for sure
I was so when I talked to him I was like
so you're telling me that because it
actually happened
um so I'm like so you're telling me that
if there's like a kid in another country
that he's never read the Bible or heard
of it or doesn't have any idea but
they're like a really good kid and they
die they're going to hell because unless
you believe in the story that's the only
way you get to go to heaven and he's
like well I'm just here to talk about
the Bible if you have any questions
about the Bible I can answer I'm like um
anything else and it's like
so many wars exist still because of
religion like yes I mean why is it why
is religion so divisive it is and it's
it's interesting because I mean like
I've I would love to you know I would
love to be religious in some way someday
just because I would love to think that
I'm more than just like an aging bag of
like bones and meat held together by a
skin sack but I that's the kind of the
issue for me too right I just I can't
make myself believe it and I hate when
people act like that's also a decision
of mine like you don't why don't you
believe it just believe it and it's like
that doesn't work that way for me and
also you know that's what I mean when I
say everyone has their sacred cows right
because there's a lot of people who walk
around like I'm not offendable I'm not
offended by everybody these these woke
[__] are ruining everything but if I
make a joke about you know Christianity
then they lose it and I'm like right
talking about everything I do mean
everything you know I including religion
and I I can say like the mildest things
sometimes about religion and people like
so I'm like no but I can and I remember
like the passive aggressive way like oh
bless her I'll pray for you yeah you're
saying I'm horrible yeah I know it's
like I don't mind if people say I'll
pray for you and they just like trying
to be nice people like oh I'll pray for
her like she's a bad girl
and it's like no like come on and I just
it's also I don't like I don't treat you
that way you know I'm not like you
believe in God and therefore I don't
like you or I don't want to hear what
you have to say or you're this religion
and I don't want to hear what you have
to say and I just want to be have the
same respect I was doing this bread and
water fast in the fourth grade like by
myself like I wanted to do it like I
wasn't forced to do it but I was like so
into it and it's just crazy for me to
think about it now because I used to
feel bad for other people like that
weren't religious I was like so what
happened what switched yeah I just I I
just I didn't believe it I just I just
couldn't believe it I think a lot of it
was
like certain sexual things being like
great any sexual things not certain
sexual things like all sexual things
being grave sins right and just being
like why and like I cannot really be
true and if this person's a great person
but they have sex before they're married
they're gonna go to Eternal damnation
and like why so that honestly
was what it was because I saw that as
being completely harmless you know I saw
that as being very much a personal
decision that you can make for yourself
and that was really what it what it was
for me yeah great we're on to the next
topic sex I love it yeah first I don't
know why it's so taboo and I mean for me
it was like growing up it was like no
like it was like really and I obviously
don't think that way anymore and I talk
way more openly about it now and I I
could it's just like the shame is so
harmful because I think there is also
this Resurgence of some people being
like if you're a woman and you have sex
and like you have set you have like too
many partners whatever that even means
and then like no you're damaged like no
one's ever gonna want you and no one
will tell these women the truth about
and it's like that's not the truth like
that's not the truth if you're a woman
who's a lot of partners then you just
you just did that you know I I think
it's it's so harmful it's so harmful to
because I think really what can be like
maybe if anything a turn off to people
could be like if you hate yourself if
you're really insecure if you do things
that don't feel right to you and then
you or you do things that do feel right
to you and you judge yourself for it
anyway I think that's people really need
to be able to be more open about it and
own it because a lot of people too who
are judgmental about stuff like that
have like weird freaky skeletons in
their closet a lot of the time too yeah
wow they say that there's like 13 of the
population is securely attached versus
the rest of the people are either
anxious attached or avoidant yeah and
I'm like 13 really I don't even believe
that like I'm not even like I'm anxious
but I I'm aware I think so I'm like what
I'm doing right now is wrong and I need
to stop and I need to apologize I'm
really self-aware I think a lot of
people are not self-aware yeah I feel
like you are really good at um doing
things that make you uncomfortable yeah
I do where does that I force myself to
yeah where does that come from
you know I think because my biggest fear
is to have not accomplished some things
I didn't try or because I was too afraid
to put myself out there and also because
I have failed
so many times and if you do stand up and
you just like have a hot bomb you know I
said I'm obviously most of my sets
weren't bombs or I wouldn't have kept
doing it but uh you know it's like okay
that's the worst that can happen and you
kind of move on I think it's way worse
to never try and that doesn't mean it
doesn't hurt but I I always I mean I
used to do these man on the street
videos I worked at bar stool and I did
man on the street videos that in like
some crazy locations like I went to a
Juggalo convention in the middle of
Thornville Ohio and it was a much
smaller operation at the time it was
just me and like some this guy Paul uh
this his name's Gaz he's like well
actually one of the shareholders he just
he was the camera guy he had like these
salmon colored shorts on and it was like
people it was like a scary environment
but it's like you have the scariest
thing to me is to not be scared because
then you don't grow and then you never
will know what could have been I hope
you're right about that in the book did
you write about that too I do yeah I do
I write about that in the book about how
safe spaces aren't real anyway because
every different person is gonna have a
different idea of what that is you know
um one person let's say somebody people
were someone was raped someone might
have their safe space be somewhere that
that's not gonna be brought up another
person their safe space who is also
right might be to be able to make jokes
about it and talk about it so it's not
real and there's also research that I
write about my book that shows that you
know that there's these positive
feelings and growth that can come from
feeling uncomfortable that can only come
from feeling uncomfortable so you don't
just feel good but you feel good in a
way that only being uncomfortable can do
for you
so I mean if I think back at all these
times in my life that were the most
meaningful Milestones I mean like
they were all a lot of them were really
scary things and it didn't even have to
be trauma but even doing stand-up comedy
is really scary or you know deciding
okay I'm going to I can't afford grad
school so I'm not going to take out a
loan I'm gonna stay here in LA and you
know try to do internship that was scary
all of the things that have been the
most pivotal moments of my life were the
scariest ones and um that doesn't mean
I'm not freaking out because I am
anxious and I do freak out the entire
time but I just say let's [__] go and
I do it anyway let's [__] go everyone
write this [__] down let's [__] yeah
and and just like do the [__] that
scares you right like I totally agree
with you what was the environment at bar
stool like was it uh how many years ago
were you at Barstool I was there like
2016 like 20 yeah it was a totally
different like yeah different office
like Dave was there and right it was a
different office I had a podcast and I
would and I would be in like once a week
often times when like nobody was there
yeah but I mostly did like these videos
in other locations like I went to Cancun
spring break and asked people political
questions that was a really funny one
and like the audio quality the video is
so good it's so funny these kids are
insane like they're wild but like the
audio quality is shitty because it was
such a smaller operation when I was
there but I went back recently to do
some of their shows just because my
books out and stuff but it's funny
because I was there like way back before
they were anything but they're cool like
I I like you know I I like doing their
stuff yeah I've been there I went there
a couple times for a couple of different
interviews and you always it's it's like
it just seems world's different than
going to work for Fox News like you know
what I mean like it's just you know we
talked about crystals and you know all
kinds of like weird [__]
um and we weren't you know like they
just totally pushed the envelope and you
know news platforms don't so did you do
you like do you like being at Fox do you
like what is what what's the biggest pro
and con of let's say like Barstool and
then Fox
see I think that saying that I work at
Fox is also almost misleading because of
the show that I do
um because it got failed we do talk
about all kinds of weird stuff
um I it is more like comedy focused
um Barstool was super fun and obviously
like you have more leeway so like that's
a pro but I also have found that I've
had a lot of leeway at cuff Feld and as
my book has come out and I've been able
to do these interviews I have said a lot
of things and I've not had a single
phone call about how I shouldn't have
said anything if you like this clip and
you want to hear the whole episode click
at the bottom of your screen